I have a new tour date to announce uh
just got back from Phoenix but I'm
announcing right now Edmonton Alberta
Canada on July 14th at Kinsman Park The
Great Outdoors Comedy Festival that'll
be interesting it's outdoors and so I'm
real curious about that we will be
putting up other shows in Canada as well
over time uh but we're excited to make
that work July 14th get tickets starting
Wednesday May 3rd at 10 A.M mountain
time with code Rat King General on sale
starts Friday May 5th at 10 A.M Mountain
Time
I will also be coming to Gilford New
Hampshire July 20th Windsor Ontario
August 18th Niagara Fall Falls
Ontario on August 20th and Toronto
Ontario on August 27th those are Canada
get all your tickets at theovan.com
t-o-u-r for your best price on tickets
we now have be good to yourself
crewnecks available in light blue maroon
and cement that embankment gang color
you know it check these out along with
the new windbreaker at theovinstore.com
and thank you for your support
today's guest is a uh multi-talented man
he's a buffet of talent he's the meat
he's the salad he's the puddin he's the
tots he's got it all
he's an actor he's a creator
um you may know him from his iconic role
on the office uh he has a new book out
called Soul boom why we need a spiritual
Revolution
uh he also has a new travel show
um that'll be coming out soon you can
check that out called the geography of
bliss he made me laugh and uh just made
me happy so many times in my life I'm
grateful to sit and talk with him today
today's guest is rain Wilson
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
you look pretty nice here I think I look
great yeah great a lot of beverages am I
okay to have this on camera well yeah
will they sue you nope you'll be fine
hey man
in all truth like it's such a pleasure
to meet you and I've been just dying at
your stuff for years I know you get this
all the time but like in all truth like
it was so surprised like Theo Von wants
you in the show like what
um I'm just I'm a huge huge fan really
oh man I I have just chortled at your
ridiculous brain for for many years and
uh for real yeah wow man that's awesome
bro no for real but no I I'm trying to
I'm honestly trying to genuinely drop in
and uh and hear that and take it in yeah
yeah it's really nice you to say yeah I
just did Bert kreischer's the oops I
just did Bert Crushers the other day and
um
and it's like you and Bert and Tom like
that whole the whole gang you got going
on like have cornered this whole section
of like comedy and social media and it's
uh I'm a huge fan anyways so it's a
universe man yeah it's a real little
universe that's really nice of you to
say man uh obviously you've
I mean you've made people laugh you
almost have to take a second when you
sit with you to get to just be with you
to get past like the um you see a lot of
Dwight going on or something like that
no no I'm seeing you I feel like but I
think there's this you have to let kind
of like the uh
you just have to let the premonitions
Fall by the wayside a bit you know or
the right the The Fog that's in before
you that you can't even help of like
just because of your life and your
talent and you know how visible you've
been
um I think there's a little bit of it
sometimes with people probably yeah yeah
you know but I feel like I'm just
sitting here with you all right cool
yeah cool awesome um and thanks man I
read the first 50 pages of your book
damn that's pretty good thank you I
thought I I figured it's a hell of a lot
better than Bert Kreischer he didn't
read page one oh man
yeah I bet if you'd have written it on
the inside of a 12-pack he'd have read
it yeah he would have you know he would
have oh he's gonna read his own Epitaph
soon dude
wow that's talking about premonitions
that got a little dark a little cold
sorry Bert want you to be alive
um but I thought it was interesting I
thought it was just it was kind of a
perfect reflection of like where a lot
of people are at in their lives right
now I think just as a society as a
species
um in like this kind of not only a quest
maybe first spirituality but an
examination of spirituality yeah what
spirituality means
um all kind of stuff like that uh so I
thought it was and we can get into it
but um
yeah I know you said that there was it's
hard for people why do they lock up the
pissers in the office buildings was
interesting why they lock them so do you
want to go from my book on spirituality
to like to locking up restrooms is that
where we is that the transition yeah I
should I do and everything at once kind
of okay
yeah so I have this problem and I think
it's a problem I don't know that it
exists in other cities but in La it's
this kind of thing where every single
bathroom needs a key and like what the
hell like just let them be open like I
understand if you've got a building like
on Skid Row Downtown like maybe you just
don't want someone setting up a tent in
there and moving in or something like
that like I get that but you'll be like
we're out here in the middle of the San
Fernando Valley what do they think like
someone's gonna wander into this
building off the street and like come in
and like do something nefarious shoot up
drugs in the in the restroom why do you
need keys yeah well they should give you
a certain if you Deuce well enough you
should get a general a key to at least
so many bathrooms that's a good idea
there could be like an app you unlock it
it's like a game it's like Candy Crush
and you play it enough you're
responsible enough citizen with your app
you get into bathrooms wherever you
could take a [__] wherever you're like
oh I'm going down the valley I'm not
going to name what stop off the 101
you're at but you know you're down the
one-on-one like oh man I really need to
go and like you you have an app it's
like when you have an app that searches
for you know charging stations for your
electric car you know you've got an app
with a little map on it and then this
allows you to come in and yeah take a
dookie yeah you're privileged yeah I can
[__] off a Victory Boulevard now yeah
and it opens up
I don't know we've got something the key
thing has got to it's a very La thing I
don't imagine they do that in Cincinnati
I imagine in Cincinnati like you just
park and you can just go in and like
take a crap somewhere without a key yeah
and people recognize that people have to
take craps I think it's like here they
almost want to pretend like
oh God you weirdo have with your body
with your bowels and your old-fashioned
urethra or whatever you have to go and
do urine or whatever like oh you peasant
you know like yeah come get a key like
they almost make it like it's an
outhouse but it's inside kind of right
right it's a it's elitist like La is so
elitist even the bathrooms are elitist
yeah you gotta go sometimes you know
what it's like sometimes you got
appointments around town and you just
really gotta go what are you gonna do
like Starbucks is really the only place
that's oh grocery stores are pretty good
do you notice that yeah there's always a
bathroom in a grocery store you'd never
think that that's like the land of
accessible bathrooms it's a long hike
you gotta get back in there I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna lie you get you pull
into a Ralph's or an amp you gotta you
gotta Traverse a couple hundred yards
before you get back to that thing and
the frozen food aisle you notice if you
Traverse down that one it feels longer
than the other aisles for some reason
does it really yeah I think so it feels
because there's it just feels feels
brighter and like kind of vibe or like
someone could have had to be doing a
party in a couple hours
that it's also maybe an optical illusion
yeah and um it's kind of like Luke
Skywalker flying the Tie Fighter through
yes down those long
yeah you're right it all feels the same
so I think there's this weird thing in
your head where it doesn't feel new for
a few seconds yeah so it's just like am
I stuck in a corridor whereas on a
regular aisle it's like these are the
red chips these are the brown uh you
know little uh cookies so it keeps
changing and it's like do you ever go
back in the back of a grocery store yeah
you gotta use the bathroom and then you
go through the employees Swinging Doors
like employees only but you have to go
back there there's a whole world back
there oh it's a magical world back there
well there's usually somebody's kind of
crying a little bit somebody has a hair
net right sure when you see that out of
the gate you know yeah and then somebody
has their hands on somebody else's back
and they're consoling them but the hands
are covered with
potato salad
blood where are you going with this I
don't know pla those plastic uh the
plastic gloves yeah the deli gloves but
then potato salad and blood on the
outside of those why so there was
obviously why do grocery stores always
have the same things in the deli section
do you ever notice that you go in you go
shopping it's like coleslaw
potato salad
like a broccoli salad just smothered in
mayonnaise yeah you got your deli meats
and cheeses but then like it's like a a
shrimp salad you don't know how old it
is it's again smothered in mayonnaise
yes
why don't they mix it up back there in
the in the deli cases of grocery stores
you know what I mean it's 2023 Theo I
think it would create a little bit of
novelty if you thought I'm gonna go see
what new they have there yeah let the
chefs in the hair nets with the plastic
gloves like let them let them be
creative let them be creative let them
be art let them be the artists that they
are The Artisans
they don't do that you don't feel a lot
of creativity when you wander into the
into that area of the store yeah it's um
that's the saddest section of any
grocery store yeah because it's cold too
you're like oh why'd they put that you
know they could at least give them some
heat
that's right that's right and the guy
everybody looks like
non-binary kind of because of the hair
nets I think everybody has sort of this
you know what everybody's running a meat
slicer it's it there's a lot going on
it's very game of thronesy right there
yeah you think so there's a lot of like
do you mean it in terms of like people
killing each other or it has an archaic
sort of guillotini kind of
because you're talking about the slicer
yeah with the slicer and then there's
sometimes there's like a meat hanging
you know yeah it's like a one like
wiener of meat like hanging from that's
true there can be a wiener chain oh yeah
so it's just yeah I think that makes you
if you're a kid and your mom takes you
by there you're like oh this isn't for
us yeah
it's where an appetite goes to die
really you know and you don't really
need to get the meats slight and they
have like a nice like head of like
pastram like pastrami or whatever and
then you say I want a pound of that yeah
but they don't open that one up they've
got another
um old one that's already been
pre-opened and they slice that one up
yeah yeah you kind of pick out the
orphan you want but they bring in the
other orphan you know oh here's a little
Ricky you know
he's got shingles but he's just as good
as his brother and you're like ah come
on you'll never know the difference yeah
um you know I worked at a grocery do you
ever work I never worked at a grocery
store I had a lot of shitty jobs in my
day but never worked in a grocery store
yeah what was that like did you stock
shelves I did stocking and I got
promoted up to the eventually the
cashier I was associate cashier and then
cashier what's an associate cashier I
didn't know that was that was a position
yeah you just stand by the cashier
bagging oh okay but they called us
associate cash here it's a bag it's a
Bag Boy it was yeah
it was dude and you didn't at the first
like two weeks you're like um but then
you realize you're not even doing it you
know you're a bad boy she went from
stockroom to associate cashier and
you're like oh I'm an associate cashier
and then it's like I want you to just
put the groceries in the bag yeah you're
like all right
you see the truth that's one of the
tough things about life sometimes is
seeing the truths you know it's one of
the tough things about moving to Los
Angeles you know you love your favorite
TV shows you love Highway to Heaven you
love Michael Landon you get out here you
realize it's
you know it just they filmed it you know
right outside of burbanks I don't know
what Highway to Heaven is and I see that
box over your head oh yeah I've never
even heard of it before is that a TV
show it was a Michael Landon TV show
yeah where you help people get to heaven
it was like he showed up and was it like
Touched by an Angel only with a dude
yeah
and Victor French was in it oh you
brought you brought it up on the uh
wait yeah who's that who's that guy
that's Victor French right there if you
click on hit the one with him and Victor
on it yeah now is it
um is it I I don't mean this in any
derogatory way but he looks very Jewish
did they did they want to kind of have a
Jewish presence
since it's about like Angels let me see
if he was Jade up or not let's look up
Victor French and see if Victor French
if you can get a Wiki on him was this a
90s thing oh he does look Jewish I
didn't realize that yeah
he was also in Little House of the
Prairies they worked together a lot yeah
yeah
they had a kind of a thing going oh yeah
he was in the little house man he was
awesome oh does it say early life maybe
early career it doesn't specify huh yeah
yeah I guess he does look kind of yeah
he does look a little bit Jewish huh
Victor or Edwin and nothing wrong with
that no not at all we're just saying oh
look there he is his spouse was named
shins so he might have married a Jewish
woman it sounds like
what decade this were you talking about
90s here yeah 80s 80s and early 90s
um but anyway I was a huge fan but yeah
just to do a podcast where you watch
episodes and like kind of like office
ladies only Highway to Heaven Bros his
office ladies watching your watch in the
office yeah that's like it's like a top
10 podcasts they get like two million
downloads a week and they just watch
office episodes and comment on them and
they're like oh it was really funny in
this episode that you know Dwight fell
down the stairs and I remember when we
were filming that that kind of thing
yeah I mean they were lovely and
delightful Jenna and Angela but it's
huge but those those watching shows
watching fan shows are good you could do
a Highway to Heaven yeah I could do
David Spade and Dana Carvey do one where
they talk to people that came on SNL oh
yeah and they have a Sopranos one you
know that one yeah something like that
could be interesting I would do you read
the first part of my book so I would do
kung fu yeah I love I love you you could
tell that you did yeah you could tell
you watched all three seasons you said
in there oh man multiple multiple times
and bring that up kung fu
with KCC he was the leader in it all he
was the question Kane yeah yeah
it's uh because I'm not familiar with it
sorry go ahead 1973 uh Seasons the
original idea for Kung Fu
uh was created by Bruce Lee
he tried to sell it they were too racist
to have
there it is yeah there's David Carney so
they got a white guy to play a Chinese
guy David Carradine and he was brilliant
but it was a very racist Choice
um by the uh by the TV networks was it
racist at the time
well you shouldn't have a white guy
playing a Chinese guy like I don't care
what decade it's in like it's I mean it
was more done back then I mean they
would have like black stunt guys that
would have white stunt guys wearing
black face literally you could see
movies where you know
um because sometimes you know what it
could have been too sometimes the
audience wouldn't accept if it was an
Asian guy they went out and watched it
as much but maybe not huh I I think that
was their fear that's their fear right
Their Fear would be that people wouldn't
watch it but anyways it's a brilliant
show he is studying uh Kung Fu in a
Shaolin Monastery in China and you know
he's the master there we see a couple of
his Kung Fu Masters teaching him the
wisdom of the East and as well as some
martial arts sick martial arts moves and
then
um he gets kicked out of the monastery
and goes to the old west in the 1880s
he's wandering around the cowboy lands
and uh fighting uh fighting crime not
really fighting crime
righting wrongs okay shall we say
um but bringing the uh his benevolent
Eastern wisdom to bear on every
interaction that he has uh they
encounter a lot of racist Cowboys out
there oh yeah oh you China man you know
spit like and then of course there's a
couple fights yeah this chopstick's got
bullets in it stuff like that that would
have been good they didn't have lines
not quite that smart but that would have
worked
um but anyways I talk about it in my
book because I feel like there it's it
is a it's a metaphor for spirituality
because in spirituality we we're walking
around the crazy chaotic old west that's
aggressive and violent and we're
bringing to Bear our wisdom and our uh
you know our our vision we're trying to
create peace bring people together he's
always got really beautiful wise things
to say
um to try and heal people but there's
always like some drunken racist Cowboy
there that you got up at the end of the
day you gotta Pony up you know but I'm
gonna make orange chicken out of you or
something like that that's good that's
good you should have been on this
for them wait that could have been good
yeah good but uh yeah well like but so
but so go on So You Think So it's like
it's kind of like we need that now we we
can use that I mean we can use that
always but that's what I kind of derived
from the beginning of your book The I
think I read like 23 of it maybe
um but that we
how do we get to where we start to look
at ourselves you want us to look at more
as ourselves as a group and not just as
individuals well that's see that and
that's the point I bring up Kung Fu
because
to me a lot of people when they think
about spirituality they think about
something I mean there's there's folks
that think of spirituality as synonymous
with church right so they like they go
to church on Sunday and that's where
they get their spirituality and they
hear a sermon but I'm talking about like
many people feel like spirituality is
something that
you know they pray or they meditate or
they read a spiritual book or the Bible
or or a philosopher or something like
that and they go to the yoga class or
something like that but that that
spirituality is something internal that
we kind of process and develop uh inside
of ourselves and
I bring up Kung Fu because I compare and
contrast it to Star Trek yeah which is
for me a different way of looking at
spirituality because Star Trek is about
the Journey of humanity itself like the
bigger picture
now true Star Trek's more about like
technology and whatnot but it's
uh in the planet on Star Trek uh
Humanity has had a big war
this is before the Original Series
starts
we've overcome racism out of that war we
we're getting along everyone's getting
along we've solved like sexism we've
solved income inequality there's like
you know great peace and Justice and and
Tranquility on planet Earth which allows
us to build all these spaceships and go
flying around the universe and seeking
out strange new life and new
civilizations and whatnot
um but there's a there's a there is a
spiritual maturity there's a progression
of humanity right toward this mature
spiritual end so I I bring I contrast
those two because I think that sometimes
people lose sight of the fact that
there can be a spiritual transformation
and maturation of us seven billion of us
on the planet and um and that's just
something important to talk about and
think about because it doesn't get it
doesn't really get brought up or
discussed that much it doesn't
um a lot of things focus on the now we
get a little bit further out when we
look at things like
um
like our own lives and stuff like that
like the limitation of our own lives
what will happen in our lifetime but
rarely do you start to think what can I
if there's an overall goal that there's
like a destination as a people or a
populace
um then isn't that and isn't that Theo
isn't that world peace really like do
you remember
I mean you're a lot younger than me but
you're no spring chicken you've been
around the block do you remember when
people used to talk about world peace
like as a as a thing as like yeah dude
yeah I mean I remember Ronald Reagan
yeah yeah you know yeah I remember
Ronald Reagan man
um
yeah but yeah I remember World Peace We
are the world I remember people were
excited about it they were like we're
mailing hands to Africa where
everything's gonna change we got this
you know David Bowie I think was doing
we should mail all those deli meats and
cheeses and the potato salad and the
shrimp salad no one no one's eating that
crap by the way it's [__] yeah I agree
jelly Goods
if you don't love swallowing pills if
you're not a pill baby you're not a pale
pill woman pillar
if you're not a pill person Pill Popper
that's where Bluetooth helps out
blue shoes chewable
tablets combat all forms of Ed that's
erectile dysfunction
and can help men gain extra confidence
for when it's time to pair form that's
right Bluetooth
licensed medical providers work with you
to find the right ingredient and
strength for your prescription
they have sildenafil and Tata laughel
and their tablets are chewable
Bluetooth Bluetooth tablets are made in
the USA and they prepare and Ship Direct
so it's cheaper than a pharmacy that's
the truth and guys here's a special deal
for you try Bluetooth free when you use
our promo code Theo at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping I like these
chewables they're good that's
blueshoe.com promo code Theo to receive
your first month for free you know the
economy has been a challenge it's always
a challenge we don't know
we don't know what the future is we just
base things on the current
and you need to make sure you keep your
business thriving
by finding ways to save money without
cutting corners
that are going to affect uh your
clientele and the products they receive
ship station can help ship station give
you access to discounts of up to 84 off
USPS and UPS rates and you can manage
every order from one simple to use
dashboard that's right ship station
effortlessly integrates everywhere you
sell online including Etsy Shopify eBay
Amazon and more
manage every order from one simple
dashboard automate routine shipping
tasks print labels compare rates they
can do it all
and with Enterprise solutions that make
Warehouse optimization easy ship station
scales when your business does
well we want to give you a a deal over
there go to shipstation.com and use code
Theo today and sign up for your free
60-day trial that's 60 days of ship
stationing that's
shipstation.com code Theo get a 60-day
free trial at
www.shipstation.com
Theo thanks to shipstation for
sponsoring this show
you know it's yeah it def it's like well
this is one thing I thought about when I
was kind of delving into your
um in your work was that
yeah it's like you feel this do you feel
compelled to kind of look at this like I
guess you're saying it's a nice somebody
needs to bring this to the Forefront of
conversation that hey we're all here is
there some bigger reason why we're all
here can we all start to look at that
again like yeah
um that we can have a goal as a species
that maybe you know mother nature and
father time have a goal for us yeah and
we've gotten very off track with our own
Society sometimes I think
American society we may a thousand years
from now look back and like man what a
detour we took yeah with a lot of the
directions we had oh my God I think it's
such a crazy I I I've been saying that
to my friend Aaron the other day like
we're just in this um
time I think that 50 100 years from now
look bad at back and be like man what a
crazy [__] up time we were in like
first of all here's what we did is we
created these mini computers right with
uh any distraction you could possibly
think of every game unlimited porn oh
social media you can connect with anyone
you can download any piece of
information you'd ever possibly want and
we just sprinkle it out like candy among
the citizenry you know just like here
here you all go you know have these
devices that and then you've got kids
growing up and they're they're never
well I remember when I was young like
you remember being bored yeah I was
bored so much as a kid I was my dad was
like you're coming with me why I have to
go to the dentist
why do I need to go well I don't want
you sitting at home
you know it's it's going to take a
couple hours and I gotta swing by the
hardware store or whatever yeah so I'll
get you okay I'll get you two feet of
rope or something like all right I'm in
you know I'll get you a candy we'll stop
by the bank my mom would say yo stop by
the bank and you get the little candy at
the at the in the aisle all right I'll
go okay so I brought a comic book and
like you just sit there and like you'd
hear he'd be in the dentist
and you're just in the waiting room and
there's like a People magazine or maybe
you brought your comic book but you've
already read it so you read it again and
yeah there's just a lot of sitting
around now kids aren't getting bored but
I'm getting off track no you're not
because it's all part of the same thing
I think your general disposite your
general thought is like
I mean we can talk about boredom I talk
about the moment doesn't exist anymore I
talk about
um
my niece thought imagination was an app
on your phone
uh you said like use your imagination
and she's like where is that I don't
have that downloaded yeah
wow and it blew my mind I was like yeah
because boredom was a chance like that's
where you came up with your that's where
your Junior came from you know
yes that's where your brain showed its
balls off you know yeah it was like
that's where like you're uh that's where
Bob uh who's the guy with the curly hair
that did all the painting Bob Ross
that's where Bob Ross showed up you know
out of the nowhere in your freaking
amygdala or whatever you know Bob Ross
yeah yeah and you had to like you'd go
up to the count of your dad's in the
back getting drilled on and you like
peek over the counter with a lady
working right there and you're like you
have no idea and that used to be an
email you know and you used to and you
think like what's her life like yeah
yeah do you have any chocolate I wonder
I wonder what she goes home to yeah yeah
it was what was she wearing under that
nurse's outfit yeah dude yeah and one
time one lady used to give me her shoe
dude and let me uh just play around with
it in the lobby right there dude like
um you had a shoe as a toy yeah my mom
would take me to this place I think it
was like a hair cutter or something the
lady in the front would give me her
heels and let me kind of think she was
you know open to people being whoever
they wanted to be or whatever at that
time and she'd let me walk around in her
heels in the lobby of the wow it's
called the Looking Glass it was like the
hair salon what town was that Covington
Louisiana okay
um yeah but um but yeah I remember that
and you don't I went to college with a
guy from Covington Louisiana did you
yeah Jed diamond is his name he's an
acting teacher now in Tennessee oh yeah
Jed diamond yeah did he teach in
Nashville
Knoxville Knoxville okay he might work
at the University too or no yeah yeah he
teaches at the University and wow that's
amazing yeah interesting I don't know
him which is because it's kind of a
small the diamonds uh they had a big
clan but he was there he is look at that
I love that we used to uh I played
hamlet in acting school and he played
Horatio next to my Hamlet oh that's
handsome
photo that's he's not as good looking in
real life as not photos looking oh those
piercing blue eyes really nice guy very
nice guy very smart guy Jed diamond out
of Covington Louisiana that's cool yeah
yeah we had uh we actually had the
tallest statue of Ronald Reagan in our
town oh that's nice which is interesting
yeah and
um
yeah that's about it but the Harvey
Oswald went to our middle school for a
little while oh that's that's good all
right so you would hear that growing up
things like that like small town lore
and stuff yeah I loved that growing up
but yeah boredom you didn't have it so
your brain got to think and contemplate
you felt like you needed to wish into
the air if you wanted anything to happen
like you had to have some connection
with the world because you needed to
like set the all your hopes on the
scales of time and that you would
whatever your dreams were you were gonna
make them happen somehow and you felt it
inside of you and now all of so much of
that and like uh are praying our moments
our peace our it all gets there's an app
for that and it gets yeah
it gets Amplified
and comedy too like I'm not a comedian
like I wouldn't know how to write an
hour and a half worth of jokes and
stories like I just wouldn't know I
would hire someone for that I guess
um if you're available but we spent so
much time bored together too so and my
friend John and I especially we would
play kung fu we would act out scenes
from Kung Fu we love that but then
you're just like walking home from the
school bus you're not checking your
phones you're throwing pine cones at
each other and at the passing cars and
then you know you see a robin take a
[__] and then you talk about like yeah
oh Birds [__] I guess you know how much
I wonder how much Birds [__] and you
just Muse on that for 45 minutes yeah so
you can catch a bird [__] you try for an
hour yeah yeah throw pine cone try and
catch it right as it's [__] yeah and
then you go home and but that's a little
cauldron it's a little petri dish of of
Comedy because you're just just
observing things and bumping up into
each other and and uh I I think it must
be harder for for Young Folks these days
because my son is 18 years old and he
gets together with his friends and they
just mostly just look at it at their
phones the whole time they're together
yeah so I don't know yeah you know it's
interesting I sound like a grumpy old
man I don't think you do I think you
sound it's I mean it's the same thing
that I think it's like is it that I
we're becoming Grumpy Old Men or is it
that we have some concern for the
intrinsic value of what it seems like to
us what it means to be human you know
and I don't know if we are like
or does nature and the gods do they have
some longer Destiny for us to end up as
robots and these are like the shell we
are like just the snails before they get
the shell you know it's like we don't
know where we are in the chain of time
you know um there was a book a science
fiction book I read well I used to read
the last science fiction it was called
City by Clifford DC Mac and it it it
every section of the book
took you through eons and Earth's
development and like there's after the
humans expired on planet Earth then it
was the dogs so then it's like a whole
chapter about dogs ruling the Earth and
then it's and then it's the ants and
then the ants rule to Earth and then I
think at the end it's like the Dolphins
or something like that so it's stories
you know set thousands of years apart
um and the dogs are living in the ruins
of humanity so there's these shells of
these cities but they're these talking
dogs and they're talking about life and
love and yeah stuff like that so yeah
maybe this is just one just Pit Stop on
the on the way of the development of
planet Earth
what do you think it makes I don't know
if it makes me I think there's some part
of me that laments that or makes me feel
sad about it because I think in some ego
way I want to feel more important than
that or I want my time period to feel
more important than that I often feel
like it's very even though I feel like
I'm aware of some of the things that you
kind of think about and the things that
you talk about in your book I feel like
I still struggle to combat those even
though I try to use things like prayer
meditation
um you know I'm in recovery so I go to
those yeah me too so I'm a part of that
group so which promotes a lot of that
sort of stuff so I I'm an ear for
brothers that are that struggle with
stuff sometimes and
um but even then it's like
it's really hard to not feel like you're
just uh on the conveyor belt sometimes
but that you
maybe we used to have a we used to dance
on the conveyor belt and like whistle
and do marshmallows and stuff and now
we're just kind of like sitting on the
conveyor belt on our phones you know I
don't know I don't want to sound too
dour what's your biggest struggle my
struggle was um what is your biggest
struggle now
probably affection
probably love and affection that type of
stuff I want to hug you right now well
I wouldn't okay okay thank you though I
mean I'm gonna wait to go I'll take it
to go I'm gonna I'm gonna wait to the
end of the podcast okay I'll give you a
big one
some guy said in a meeting when they ate
even he goes you know what man you're
hard to pet
hard to pet yeah
and I kind of I've valued that it kind
of taught me something about myself like
you know you're right man I'm hard to
pet uh-huh I don't it's hard for me to
let people pet me hmm
that's a that's a great way of putting
it it was just an interesting Insight
um
what affection you do you mean like
intimacy like yeah I think like with
good friends and with like uh
relationships and girlfriends and
whatnot yeah I think probably like
commitment and like that kind of stuff
intimacy like really dropping in to
connecting with somebody
um I think it's kind of tough
uh I know it's kind of tough for me yeah
you know I but I don't want to talk too
much about myself
you know okay what about yourself
um I mean obviously a lot in your book
and a lot in your show you know that
you're search you're in a searching
space yeah I you know I'm in recovery
um I have a lot of anxiety I've dealt
with a lot of depression before a lot of
loneliness
um I've been through some really dark
times
um and uh
you know so for me like part of the
spiritual search and why I'm writing
about it and talking about it and
thinking about it so much is
I need tools to help me cope with my
anxiety and help me find peace and
serenity
and
and as I undertake that Journey so I
view kind of my anxiety disorder as
something almost akin to diabetes where
you have friends with diabetes and every
day they gotta take their blood right
monitor give them an apple or something
they fall over right exactly shovel some
applesauce in their mouth real quick and
yeah we had this one dude we'd always
freaking just put one of them Twix in
him bro anyway
I mean I never did that anal Twix I
haven't but they kind of shaped
perfectly right
uh so but I have to do the same thing
with anxiety like I have to uh I have to
not nothing is not anal but I have to
monitor it every day and I can live with
it and I do okay but I do have I have to
meditate I have to work out I have to
pray I have to surrender I have to stay
connected with people I can isolate
pretty easily yeah so
um
but that has led me on on the search so
I I would say my biggest struggle is
with my own
as with my anxiety and with my ego too
hmm you know yeah ego is so scary isn't
it
I must be
I mean I've been at it for a long time
and I struggled a lot more with ego like
early on in the success of the office
and stuff but must be hard for you like
you were
you're toiling away in obscurity doing
like Chuckles Comedy Hut in Oklahoma
City and then
all of a sudden like just the last like
four years like you've just like blown
up and like you're practically gonna be
put on Mount Rushmore it's a crazy
amount of
Fame for a you know a itchy Hillbillies
such as yourself you know you're right
dude that's a good call yeah I think uh
oh well it scared me that has to have
been a that has to be a struggle too oh
it's the first thing was a sheer fear I
thought this was a this was crazy I
thought God has some this was the worst
part that happened I thought God has
some special purpose for me and that
there's something special that he needs
me to do but he does and and that may be
true he has that for everyone I think
right yeah but I now you have a platform
and so you know I feel like I have some
responses with increased power comes
increased responsibility yeah heavy is
the head that wears the crown bro yeah
and you almost wearing the podcast Crown
yeah well they called me the Rat King
you know and I didn't even pick it out
you know it's just the king of rats but
um but that was real scary Ant-Man you
can order rats around
do you have a psychic connection to rats
by the way I think like think about
Ant-Man like that pitch meeting at
Marvel like all right okay Ant-Man
what's his power yeah he can turn tiny
and you picture them like
uh
that's pretty good I mean that could be
fun we don't have a shrinking guy but
it's not quite enough we need something
more
um he has a psychic power to be able to
call ants to help him out also he can
shrink
and communicate with ants
we'll call him Ant-Man
but the two Powers really aren't related
at all do you know what I mean yeah I
think it would be like Superman's power
is he has strength and he can fly and he
can also read books backwards yeah you
know I mean like it doesn't right right
and he can also weigh a Christmas ham
with his eyes right right yeah yeah yeah
that's yeah I think I don't know if well
I think Hollywood has done a they've
done a disservice to imagination because
it's been now I think it used to be a
novel place where more people came they
came out in their wagons from Kalamazoo
with their bag of ideas on their back
yep and now I think it's just you know
someone so son or grandson they're in
the seventh generation of their Studio
or film they haven't had a new idea that
isn't based on an algorithm walking the
door in 12 years and they wouldn't know
something novel and unique unless it
beat them upside the head I think a lot
of times now that might be a very narrow
view of Hollywood but by why you guys
like Bert and you and Tom I'm sure
there's others but those are the main
three that I watched like
you don't have you don't have to pitch
anything you can just make your own [__]
and hundreds of thousands of people or
millions of people are gonna watch it
and you get to do your own like Bert's
got a whole Enterprise over there he's
got movies going and oh yeah he's got a
family cooking me and David Spade just
wrote a movie together who is Mike Hall
my my one of my childhood Heroes that's
amazing yeah yeah and you didn't need to
go into Sony and like pitch it or
anything like you just kind of did it
yeah just yeah it'll sell but is it Joe
Dirt 2 I wish it was damn Joe Dirt seven
they made Joe Dirt too but they made I
didn't know either I didn't know that I
mean I knew but I didn't want you know
nobody was saying that they knew but um
but it was it was something like uh
this one's about Busboys like the last
bus boys
you know and we think if we become
waiters and everything in our life will
change you know but we just it's just a
misguided thought isn't that so true
I remember I was
very
yeah I always struggling as an actor and
then like oh once I get on a TV show
then I'll be happy and guess what
I'm on the office
and then it was just like well how do I
get to be a movie star now I'm a TV star
and like the second I'm TV star I can't
even like enjoy it yeah like a month I'm
on to like like
how do I get to how do I get to be a
movie star and guess what it didn't work
out so well for me trying to do movies
you mean yeah the movies move my movies
never people never really liked or saw
my movies very much um one day you'll
probably make a really neat movie that
people will see well I think a lot of
them were neat and and people tell me
they like them now like The Rocker and
stuff like that but like that was my big
I don't know if you remember that movie
The Rocker so you don't even know it
existed yeah what about you you know
about it I saw it in theaters you saw it
in the theater hell yeah bro thanks Zach
for holding the team together wow that
was 14 years ago how old were you
must have been 16 or something like that
there he is
there it is and Bradley Cooper and the
oh yeah I remember seeing the average
yeah Oh I thought this was John uh
what's his name Barry
Bill Hader yeah yeah I used to kind of
look like Bill Hader when I was a little
better looking and younger
you still seem like a handsome guy oh
you're stop you
um
but anyways this was like oh I'm putting
all my eggs in this basket The Rocker
um this is my chance my starring role in
a comedy movie and it was one of the
biggest bombs in Fox history yeah it
opened on like
there's this thing called per screen
average I mean truth be told they move
the launch date like five times they
pushed it to a release after like Labor
Day
like literally like the worst weekend
everyone's getting ready to go to school
yeah um that's the worst it came out
like three weeks after Tropics Thunder
and two weeks after Step Brothers so
there were all these amazing comedies in
the theater already we just and like the
came out in like two thousand or three
thousand screens and like the per screen
average was like
203 or something like that and it's like
it was brutal I put I worked so hard on
it I promoted the hell out of it and no
one wanted to see the rain Wilson
starring vehicle and it was devastating
but why you know why was I in such a
place back then and I think I'm in a
different place now where it's like you
say about the busboy like oh if only I
can get to be a waiter then my life will
be made
um but oh if only I can be
I'm a TV starf only gonna be a movie
star then I will be happy yeah you know
but but then you want to walk on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame or then you want
you know your kid to be a movie star you
don't mean anything I you know yes I
think that search for different things
never really ends but I think we have to
try and monitor where does that search
come from right and what are exactly we
searching for and that's the kind of
thing honestly not to go back to your
book but I think it that's kind of some
of the stuff that is touching on it's
like where some of these motivations
coming from not only for me as a person
but where's our motivation coming from
as a specie and as a human if we want
external validation if we want to find
happiness extreme extrinsically that's
outside of ourselves
um you know we're never we're never
going to be satisfied we have to find
um that deep soul-rich satisfaction of
being alive you know in the garden of
our hearts you know tending to you know
what fulfills us and brings us joy and
talk about being in the moment you know
that's such a key part of it it's hard
um and then when we're able to cultivate
that then we're able to spread that and
give that to others you know and one of
the things that you get to do and I
think you're great
Divine and solemn responsibility and I
put the rat king crown on your head and
anoint you King Rat and I say to you you
are a spreader of joy
you make people laugh you spread Joy you
spread ideas you uplift people there's
probably some really depressed guy right
now sitting in a trailer park in Mobile
Alabama taking a [__] and he doesn't
know where he's going to pay the next
month rent and he's listening right now
to this as he's watching and he's
chortling in all of your analogies and
your your verbal sense of humor and your
and your humble demeanor and and and
he's uplifted and and that that is uh
that is a divine power that is your
Ant-Man Powers is to is to uplift and
inspire
not just summon rats hmm
or summon decent rats
yeah
yeah because that's really the best hope
to be is just a d you know be a decent
rat be a decent rat I like that I kind
of like that too man is that gonna be on
your merch page now it could be we can
put it on there yeah yeah we can put a
deal you put my little face there on it
all right
um what's your name again
Alex Zach my brother's name is Alex you
can name him Zach or Alex
um you can name him Alex Zach it's nice
to have him there because he smiles when
it's funny yep someone's not really an
audience right there isn't you also have
to recognize his sin his sense of humor
may not be the same as yours so
sometimes you might be being funny and
he doesn't he is deadpan Stonewall he
doesn't fake it really for you which I
like yeah it feels authentic it feels
legit I think he I I think that but I've
already I've worked I got a couple
Giggles out of Zach yeah I try I'm
honest with it he is honest with it he's
out of Cincinnati and he's honest with
it I would say that that's about him was
he from Cincinnati that's what I said
about bathrooms in Cincinnati yeah
that's krp right
the turkeys from the sky remember then
oh they shot turkeys out of the air they
threw turkeys out of the sky in that
show that's what that's the only thing I
remember I never saw those before WKRP
in Cincinnati you ever saw that show
yeah so yeah I used to watch that in the
70s golden age of uh the sitcom All in
the Family I loved it God he was good
Carol O'Connor have been to his grave
seven times
you've been to Carol O'Connor's grave
seven times yup that is that is a
devotion and dedication where is where
is his grave in my backyard yeah that's
why I was mowing the lawn every time I
mowed the lawn that was Carol O'Connor
he's buried in my heart
where's his grave he's buried in
Westwood there's a cemetery in Westwood
okay uh right by UCLA yep I thought
that's one with like a thousand soldiers
in it nope oh there's that one but
there's another little one like a
quarter of a block okay it's behind some
business buildings you never think it's
there Hugh Hefner is in there Marilyn
Monroe
Carol O'Connor
um who's the guy from uh who are the two
old guys from the angry grandpas where
they're in the boat and they're hitting
them Walter Matthau yep Walter Matthau
it's pretty good I got that yeah like
who the angry old God of them and Jerry
matineau and the last one is the other
guy Jack
lemon lemon
both of Grumpy Old Men were buried there
all buried there in the same Cemetery
wow and the first guy that ever played
Robin Hood
Kevin Costner I thought he was still
alive oh no Tarzan
or Robin Hood
I'm Googling this [__] someone
um
maybe it could have been him could have
been Pierce Brosnan too
he's still alive
oh then not him congrats Pierce
well done Pierce
um it's amazing have you ever subscribed
to something and forgot about it
I have
I did I was part of a scarf annual
and I send you a scarf every month
thank God your neck just can't handle it
dang
I was getting dang hives just because I
had you know by may I had on three
scarves and I just people couldn't
recognize me
it's getting dangerous two couldn't see
over the top one
well rocket money can help you cancel a
subscription one that you forgot about
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they've forgotten about
like that stars app that you bought just
one time to watch a show or that free
gaming trial that you never used all of
them rocket money real quickly and
easily find your subscriptions for you
and for any you don't want to pay for
anymore just hit cancel and Rocket money
will cancel it for you it's that easy
stop throwing your money away and cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com
t-h-e-o that's rocketmoney.com
Theo
rocketmoney.com Theo
UFC 288 is sure to pack a punch with a
high stakes first matchup between Al
Jermaine Sterling and Henry sehudo
who will secure the bantamweight title
place your bets on DraftKings Sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
UFC new customers can make a five dollar
bet and score one hundred and fifty
dollars in bonus bets instantly
plus everyone can take the MMA action to
the next level with DraftKings same game
parlays combine multiple bets for a shot
at an even bigger payout
just download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app now use code Theo and bet five
dollars on any UFC 288 and get one
hundred and fifty dollars in bonus bets
instantly that's this Saturday on
DraftKings Sportsbook with code Theo
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for offer details C DraftKings
cold turkey may be great on sandwiches
it surely could
but there's a better way to break your
habits than cold turkey
we're not talking about some weird thing
your crazy neighbor does we're not
talking about doing a seance on somebody
or doing exorcism on a ex-husband
we're talking about our sponsor fume and
they look at the problem in a different
way
not everything is a bad habit not every
bad habit is wrong so instead of a
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bad from your habit
fume is an Innovative award-nominated
device that does just that instead of
electronics fume is completely natural
instead of vapor fume uses flavored air
and instead of harmful chemicals fume
uses all natural delicious flavors you
get it instead of bad fume is good it's
a habit you're free to enjoy and makes
replacing your bad habit easy
That's right The Taste the feel the look
man it's nice I mean the look alone is
beautiful real wood God feels
fancy in your hand
stopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy join fume and accelerating
Humanities break up from destructive
Habits by picking up the journey pack
today
had to tryfume.com and use code Theo to
save 10 off when you get the journey
back today
that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code Theo to
save an additional 10 off your order
today
I know you talked some about in your
book about how like so some of the
things something that we struggle with
is or one thing that you like to take
note of because I don't want to say like
you're being accusatory towards Society
because it's more like you're saying hey
let's all look at some of this stuff you
think that's a fair statement
yes
um it's just education like the
educations what we educate
youth on it all really
to me a lot of it is asinine
I talk about
later on in the book I talk a lot about
how
systems are broken this is where I get a
little I wax a little philosophical I'm
like so many systems are broken anyone
who works in any system will tell you
how broken it is you ever notice that
like you talk to someone who's like a
bus driver like what's it like being a
bus driver is like well it's gone to
[__] yeah I'll tell you why they're
making us work 14 hours and not enough
people and we don't get to park the
buses downtown and it's BYOB yep and you
get yeah you got to wipe down the seats
yourself we used to have guys that wipe
down the seats and you know every system
is broken down because it's everything's
based on on Greed you know everything's
based on aggression and greed and one
upsmanship and competition and
um you know and health care and
Agriculture and and education is one of
those systems
and the reason I bring all this up is
not to be like negative Nelly but to
kind of say like we uh need to uh
realize that they're based on faulty
systems like take education and I talk
about
when they pull people and they're like
hey what do you want to learn in school
people will be like
gardening
you know are how to have a friendship or
how to take rejection or how to you know
work on a car engine or how to pay bills
right and and have like a banking
account you know all the stuff that they
people say they want you don't ever
spend you don't learn [__] about that
you spend my son is 18 like some of the
stuff like his math class it's like give
me a break like he's not going to be a
mathematician and he's in like this
it's so hard and it's so pointless and
yeah and you get something out of math
like you it it exercises your brain
right it's like Advanced Sudoku right
um which is good for brain oh yeah but
it's not practical at all and like he
took this history class and his entire
history class like European history was
just about who won what battle you know
in 1707 the French beat the Polish and
in 1842 the English Beat the Dutch and
yeah and the Dutch beat the gays and
you're like what is this hey yeah
where's this going yeah like who's
writing this yeah yeah I agree man but
who cares about that like who who cares
who won the Battle of shish kebab and
you know in 1684 you know yeah 100 I'd
much rather learn how to how to you know
if I was 17 to have a checking account
or how to grow a cabbage yeah oh I'd be
sick dude you saw some freaking hot
chick with a balance checkbook and two
heads of lettuce you know what I'm
saying buddy
but dude yeah I agree there should be CL
like I always thought there should be
classes on like
um like we had spelling every week right
three kids did the best 16 kids did
medium four kids could not spell ever
yeah and it was the same for the whole
like after four weeks let's just say
we get we know what's gonna happen yeah
let's move on like I think let the four
kids yes just Duke It Out Among
themselves yeah I was always in the
medium yeah I was a good speller you're
a good speller yeah did you ever make it
to some kind of finals I made it almost
but I missed on inconvenience right
that's inconvenient yeah I wrote that
line on the in the office
um uh I lost the spelling bee I
misspelled the word failure
and uh I actually wrote that line I felt
kind of proud of that hey Zach
yeah give us a tough word let's have a
little spelling bee all right
Renaissance
um mirror him
the fair of the motel
uh the fair all right
r-e-n-a-i-s-s-a-n-c-e no
Renaissance r-e-n-n-a-i-s-s-a-n-c-e
just one in he's right you got it
well it's also you have two ends in your
name so you probably where it's like I
was sure it was two ends I was so sure
two s's okay let's do best two out of
three then
I'll and I'll pick a category two
Outdoors just Google
spelling bee words
okay I won't pick a category then I'll
take my category back
um
these are all easy these are for babies
hold on look up harder spelling bee
words I did High School
senior year Community College yeah
gesticulate
oh g-e-s-t
-i-c-u-l-a-t-e
pretty easy talking with your hands
being Italian even doing that too
yeah I think here's a class you should
have right rain
eye contact
what a great class the first week it's
all eye contact how you doing Betty you
know what do you what do you what about
the second week then you move up you do
nodding
[Laughter]
so why don't you just say like
interpersonal communication yeah
yeah you put that you're scaring off a
lot of folks that's okay let them be
scared okay kids need it people need it
right now you know you look on college
campuses and some of the most popular
classes like the most popular class at
USC is on friendship
like how to have friendship yeah well
it's yeah I mean because look what we do
you yeah I think you do eye contact
nodding you if you you do well in
nodding you get to you get to move into
the handshakers Union right and then
you're there you're doing real
handshakes in real time with people
right right but you're learning yeah how
to communicate how to take rejection
like you said that would be great oh
damn you suck oh man all right bro but
I'm still good at this right but we
teach it's like we go straight from like
dinosaurs to sex ed it's like you
believe in Tyrannosaurus Rex let's [__]
you know
[Laughter]
like that's crazy bro yeah we there's so
much as right none of it is based on no
one has ever [__] a dinosaur
oh I I believe no because they never
overlapped humans and dinosaurs never
overlapped it's like million a year
after the last dinosaur died before
humans there's no pictures of humans and
dinosaurs at the same time
well there's no there's no pictures
before 1880
paintings but yeah there was no there's
no wall carving woolly mammoths yeah it
could be that someone [__] a woolly
mammoth oh yeah in the plasticine
brunettes they called them back then
yeah you know art they're so woolly yeah
oh especially on a cold night yeah oh
sure oh oh sure I would braid that tail
it would sleep in that vagina oh yeah
it's like a rucksack you know
oh I bet if they had a newborn baby if
they're riding on a woolly mammoth they
just plop that right in there yeah yeah
why not
um
that's the only sound that they hear
they do
All Aboard trains leaving the station
but they don't [__] dinosaurs
um but that's him you know I think yeah
like getting back to being human do you
sometimes I will romanticize Native
American and tribal people and the
connection that they had to the Earth do
you do that I do very much I I really uh
believe that we have a lot to learn from
Native American folk
um the way that by and large they lived
in harmony with the natural world and
the thing I think about with a lot of
indigenous peoples in their spiritual
practices is that spirituality wasn't
separate from nature
and when you think about that it can be
very inspiring you know what I mean like
this mountain is Holy you know this
river is the river of our ancestors this
is where our ancestors are buried in
this forest and that's holy let's pray
to the spirit of the mountain or to the
spirit of the of the river of the spirit
of the forest and so it isn't this idea
of God as this kind of dude like a deity
like a like with superpowers right you
know up on a cloud yeah it's merged into
the natural world the beauty the Majesty
the Wonder the Wonder The Mystery of the
natural world you know the winds the
four directions and when you read about
Native American spirituality I think it
can be very uplifting and it was very it
was very helpful to me because I um
was reading some stuff about
um in the Lakota Sioux tradition the the
god of the Lakota Sioux is called is
referred to as wakantanka which means
the great mystery so even the word for
God instead of maybe we should all do
that is throw away the word god it's
such a loaded word right except for
Michael Landon in this Highway to Heaven
but that
um and just substitute the great mystery
like you know did you did you pray to
the great mystery today or right oh
thank the great mystery or ask the great
mystery for help or like you know create
Mystery damn it yeah I don't know yeah
but I I really love that idea and that
was very resonant for me as a young
person because I was really struggling
with God and higher power and I didn't
know what that meant to me and you know
my parents were religious but I didn't
have the same conception that they did
and that really allowed me to kind of
have a different vision for what a
higher power could be which was
something that is not separate from
nature and something that is not
separate from physical reality it is in
physical reality and and in nature and
and yet part of it and also above it at
the same time and the idea I love
I was gonna say I love mysteries but I
don't mean like I love mystery podcasts
I mean I love
you know I just love as an artist I love
the idea of life being this mystery and
uh so I I found that very helpful and I
think we could get real humble and we
really screwed over Native Americans in
this country and yeah we should go back
to the reservation and help them out and
and learn from them and not you know
tell them what to do and when to do it
but actually be humble and learn from
them because they might have something
to teach us
a great I mean I think we I think we're
start there's a lot of people that are
trying to get back to those spaces now I
think in a lot of ways you know you see
it with like a lot of Ayahuasca use and
people getting back to the jungle and
having experiences that really bring
them closer to Nature yeah
um but I can imagine yeah I'm not gonna
litter if I think that the ground has
some semblance of sacredness of course
not right things are gonna have so much
more value to me yeah I'm not gonna
strip mine that mountain right and uh
cause an ecological disaster you know
there's all these floods that have been
happening in West Virginia and they they
call them when they were doing all the
strip mining in the 70s and 80s they're
like this is gonna be an ecological
disaster because you're wiping out all
these trees and you're just digging
these trenches and digging up the coal
you know from these mountainsides and
then when it rains and floods you know
you just you're you're [__] yeah um
but if those mountains were sacred
the people wouldn't tolerate it you know
because you can have both you can have
jobs
and you can have sacred land
yeah we kind of sold our I mean I think
about that a lot like especially in the
US did we like sell ourselves out or did
we how did we get on this wrong path
where
um
or are we on a wrong path you don't know
but it feels like
there's some there must be something
more if so many people are looking for
meaning I think and feeling you know
something real
um
and especially before we get so trapped
into the digital universe that you can't
even come out I mean there a smile might
be in a museum one day you might have to
go to a museum to see a smile I like the
Museum of smiles
but that'd be so crazy yeah remember
Rick
you'd be right up there yeah remember
when Eddie got his first remember
remember when Eddie orgasm yeah remember
when Eddie got his first orgasm he's
just like
it's not quite a smile okay okay like uh
you go to the curator like that's not
technically a smile it's a Grimace of
Ecstasy but it's not quite a smile like
hey it's our biggest attraction buddy
all right calm down
I think too like we're at you know we
talked about people in the future
looking back at this time we talked
about phones and distractions and
boredom but the other thing too is like
the amount of disunity and the fact that
America is so divided 49 on each side
Democrat and Republican and this
partisanship and the how deadlocked it
is and how much fighting there is
um and it's and it's really it's so sad
because we've so many problems that need
fixing you know and
you know like Republicans might
criticize Democrats like oh they're
running their cities terribly and
there's all this homelessness and they
kind of mock it right on Fox News and
then the left does the same thing
they'll be like to find some other
problem in repo Republican states and
like and then make fun of that and it's
like why aren't we helping each other
like why why is partisanship become the
de facto way to kind of do business like
it doesn't it doesn't make sense it's
not practical it doesn't get [__] done
and it's not helping anyone and we
really need to move past it you know I
was thinking about
um debates
and uh isn't it funny on like you watch
a political debate and then immediately
there's articles like an hour later like
who won the debate and the reason that
they say that they won the debate is
they got more zingers in on the other
person
and then that's who we elect is the
person who is able to get more zingers
in on the other person as if that's a
leadership skill could you imagine
you're running for class president as a
senior in high school and like you know
it's it's it's Bobby and Darren and like
Bobby's like well Darren's got a such an
overbite you know he looks like a
woodchuck
let's vote for him like no the teachers
would never allow that looks now what's
your policy position how are you going
to help the school like how are you
going to fix Darren's teeth how are you
how are we going to have a fundraiser
for braces for Darren and his poor old
everybody yeah like I agree but yeah
it's that is well the news something
happened when the news fell off it used
to feel like and we talk about this
sometimes on here that you could rely on
the news right yeah I feel like my
parents and your parents probably felt
like the news uh had a general interest
in the wellness of their viewer yeah and
now it does not it feels like the news
wants to be like a nicotine for their
viewer
um right and that uh outrage keeps you
watching and if you read if you look
through like Yahoo news feed online I'm
not talking about like cable news but it
works in cable news too if they keep you
outraged yeah they keep you coming back
people like they always end like the end
of the new show like yeah after the
commercial you won't believe yeah what
this kid did to this man's face yeah
with a baseball bat yeah after these
messages this guy hit a two run double
on this senior citizen like Jesus wow
yeah that's a terrible baseball analogy
some guy's dead yeah man's head
found locally we'll be back right after
this still alive and it'll say and
you're like what did you use it
a show picture
yeah it makes you but then like they're
you feel like there's a swing to
everything so it's like are we just
hopefully at this point of the pin it
you know we're at the out and then
there's a turn that we can't see that's
coming or that maybe we hope for you
know because I wonder if people have
thought this way in the past as well if
people have felt as nervous about the
future well Civil War
oh that had to be definitely huh yeah I
mean that was
that that resulted in hundreds of
thousands of deaths right you ever hit
any of the reenactments or anything
probably not where you're from you're
from the Northwest right from Seattle
yeah we have reenactments but you got to
go to probably well you probably you'd
fit right in a crowd dude we'd be out
there at the cwrs bro freaking chilling
bro
what is the cwr Civil War reenactment oh
okay yeah yeah
and uh yeah just did you did you all
being from the south be like okay we're
gonna need 20 Yankees and like no
no
yeah Theo you gotta be Yankee I don't
want to be a [__] Yankee like the
South will rise again like everyone
wanted to be well people kept Southerner
people played a lot of like southern
music and [__] you know because the
party was better for the South and
before that like it was like the
breakfast or whatever the big breakfast
they would do before the fight or
whatever was definitely because the
South loses every time you know there
was one day where they kind of won but
it was like
um
you know historically they've lost and
so yeah sometimes you'd have groups from
the north that would come and they would
do it it was like a big deal oh you'd
have Yankee reenactors come down and
yeah it's like a Renaissance Fair kind
of but they would know that they were
going to win so they'd be like [__]
Y'all yeah there was a lot of that but
there was also like you know afterwards
everybody would have you know have a
michelobra slits you know and try to
like sometimes they would do it around
the same time as a renaissance fair and
people would come over and everybody try
to like bang some chick from the
Renaissance Fair so they Buxom oh man
right God did they I'll say this about
the renaissance fair dude hot chicks no
no chicks Civil War reenactors right
none a lot of masturbation a lot of
people drawing Cooter in the dirt and
stuff you know and [__] woolly
mammoth carcasses yeah right and left
yeah yeah a lot of people writing girl
on their Buddy's butt you know a lot of
like a lot of obtuse ideas out there
yeah yeah but uh oh Renaissance Fair God
oh yeah I could see you at a Renaissance
fan I could be honest yeah have you been
to some I have been I'm a huge fan I
actually wrote
a a pretty hysterical script called
Renaissance men that comedy that took
place at a Renaissance Fair
um we tried to sell it for years we
tried to get it going
um but it didn't really take off it's
very funny do you wanna would you like
to be in it yeah
could you find someone else to to be in
that yeah man or woman you think man
it's a buddy comedy two guys yeah you
can find someone else to be in it yep
what kind of guy does the other guy have
to be
well I don't know so there's one guy
that's really intense and takes a
Renaissance Fair like really seriously
he's a little bit more of a Dwight
character and the other guy's more of a
player and like seducing the ladies and
like doesn't take it as seriously yeah
they could be the player guy yeah who
wants to throw an accent in my butt you
know what I'm saying I don't know what
you're saying I literally I don't know
what you mean get your motor running
yeah so maybe the music will be a little
bit like from a different era though
yeah that's that's not the right okay it
would be like a Madrigal okay like
Rapunzel like let me go get Rapunzel
like green sleeves
I lost my love you do me wrong to have
cast me out so disdainfully God
Something Beautiful about that and I
have loved you so long I fare thee well
with my hair so free I don't know the
rest of it but
it sounds good man I'm serious I'm gonna
send you the screen yeah I'd love to
read it I really would that'd be an
honor actually because you guys this new
you youngins near young podcast
generation you and Bert could do it oh
well Bert just did a movie too yeah he
just did a movie about the machine about
being the machine yeah yeah
um you talk about uh
you talk about faith
in your book yeah
what's that been like for you and like I
know in in Hollywood a lot of times
seemed like there's not a lot of faith
in it I mean it's a very business world
you know and maybe the world is overall
I don't want to just I pick on Hollywood
a lot good you should but it's very uh
I don't know you know I like faith I
like having something other than myself
in the world I need it yeah I do too
yeah
um yeah it's I tell you something
I was thinking about this the other day
like there's a lot of weirdos in the
comedy World in Hollywood
and everyone kind of Prides themselves
on being like Oh I'm eccentric and I'm
weird and this and that and but for me
it was always a little weird because I'd
always want to talk about faith and God
and the soul and life after death and
kind of big Concepts and whatnot
and the comedy world just did not know
what to do with me like who is this guy
who's talking about God it's the
unsexiest uncoolest thing to to talk
about
anywhere and but especially like in the
too cool for school comedy world so
you've got all these eccentrics and
misfits and losers as they describe
themselves but then they also want to be
cool they want to be like the cool kids
in the lunchroom right the cool kids
table
so it was it was always hard for me
because I always wanted to talk about
that stuff and people just didn't know
what to do with that guy he's also weird
that guy who plays Dwight but then he
talks about spiritual topics and stuff
well The Gods Must Be Crazy it was a
huge movie wasn't it yeah yeah it was I
remember somebody snuck that in our
apartment when I was a kid and we
watched that's a South African movie
about the about the coke bottle yeah
yeah that fell down from the sky yeah I
was like what is this even about but
we've watched it probably 30 times
family man have you seen that
yeah with uh Nicolas Cage God is it good
huh yeah I love that movie dude I love
that I'm a big family man guy I've never
met another family man fan I think it's
terrific and it kind of came and went I
think it's a Christmas classic me too I
played it for a girl at Christmas
recently yeah she didn't pay attention
fell asleep during it oh and we don't
date anymore good good
and that was it for me bro right yep
yeah family man oh the one where the guy
uh Quaid talks with his through the
radio the radio yeah yeah
I loved that movie yeah right that was
good the ghost of his father like yeah
the radio yeah God that was powerful
that was good frequency frequency God
that was good yeah I mean that hit me
right in the freaking heart nuts man
um but you were talking about God and
faith and um yeah I don't think it turns
people off I think people are desperate
for it well it's it's a different day
now it's a different age and it's funny
because I just did Bert Bert's podcast
and uh his is a lot bigger than yours
like in what studio size no like numbers
like he's his his is huge oh you're
making that up
I'm just trying to sorry sorry I was
trying to incite something and you are a
little bit and you are and I like it I
was getting yeah I was getting it I like
it I have no idea that hurt I just know
that you guys are very very popular but
it was so great because Bert it was so
refreshing because he's like oh you
wrote a book on spirituality that's so
cool
um what do you talk about like oh I talk
about God and he's like I love God God
is awesome I totally believe in God I
love God you know and he's like and it
was like it was yeah it was so cool to
hear that from like a top comedy guy who
was just able to just say
you know it's a different it's a
different time right now and I think
because things aren't working out so
well and we see big problems and people
are turning and and this is what soul
boom is about
I want it up on that
shelf one of these days you know what
I'll put it up actually you know what
I'll put it in front of This Book for a
while you put it in front of Jordan
Peterson yeah I'd be glad to oh thank
you I really I really uh enjoyed the 50
pages that I read all right yeah I hope
you read the next 50. I think there's a
lot of things we talk about it in here
but I think people are are more open to
spiritual ideas because the other you
know political Solutions and economic
and legislative kind of it's not working
you know it's not work things are
breaking down and people feel that right
it's let us down you know I think it's
you know people used to feel a sense of
purpose more we were talking about this
a few weeks ago with the school
shootings and stuff I think some of the
reasons why you get these folks is you
have people that have no sense of
purpose right they don't get it through
their job anymore because it's a lot of
big companies and there's not the the
place in your town that makes like
you know your favorite shoes my dad
works at the shoe company and we wear
the shoes my dad makes and there's a
sense of Pride that like a place was
connected to a product you know and it
was and you're part of your
personalities and you went into work
because you knew your kid was going to
be wearing the thing and you wanted to
have a you wanted to [__] get home
and see have a sense of something in the
home when you got there you know
um and just like there's no sense of
purpose through work a lot of people
don't have a family they're not not in
love or loved and so you don't have a
sense through love of purpose but let me
add to that okay and this is has to do
with religion like so much of America
has turned away from religion and so
many young people have and for a good
reason there's been a lot there's a lot
of
shitty things about organized religion
oh a lot of pervs out there a lot of you
know a lot of big dogs you know touching
kiddos and you know being molesters you
know yeah yeah and also like church can
be very judgmental you know of people
you know gays and lesbians and and
whatnot and they can it can it can you
know cause a lot of disunity in in ways
but we people have also lost purpose as
they've lost their sense of uh of the
community that uh religious faith can
give you know because what does religion
give you gives you community a shared
sense of purpose you know Transcendence
love like service like service projects
you know I have friends that are part of
churches or in my own Baha'i faith you
know going out and doing service
projects on the weekend together working
together side by side praying together
common prayer singing together right
potlucks like just like there's we've
jettisoned everything having to do with
religion but there are a lot of
positives that come from that world oh
pot looks like pretendance having to
pretend somebody's casserole is good to
their face dude yeah yeah and the good
casseroles are taken like right off the
bat oh yeah like someone comes in with
like a tater tot and cheese casserole
with ground beef oh and it's like the
pan is dry as soon as it turns 18
brother it is off the table yeah yeah
and then but someone else brought you
know the green bean salad like yellow in
it yeah vinegar and uh and it's like
there's plenty of that left why don't
you have some of the green bean salad
the tater tots are gone but
dig in there's a bird there's like a
walk not even eating and just walking on
it like ah this is bad but no I agree a
sense of community those are things that
I love about church you see a sense of
community you know kids get to see each
other on the weekend it's things like
that yeah you get that in 12-step
meetings yeah oh a ton of it yeah it's
why I go man pottery and it's why I go
yeah I see people that care about me and
that I care about I forget there's a I
have a forgetter in me that my heart has
a quick forgetter in it you know
um it forgets that I care about people
in a way and I got to see them you know
but the second I walk into an a meeting
I see like oh Jimmy's getting a year
chip today and man
and I've seen him in 50 meetings and I'm
[__] it's like I'm his like I'm his
actual blood brother and I couldn't be
more happy for him you know beautiful
yeah there's just something about it you
know being in a place like that there's
things like AAA and recovery meetings
that make that make me feel hopeful
about Society right right you know and
that and I love the way that uh 12-step
meetings are run like there's no leaders
yeah there's no clergy there's no one in
charge um
there's no uh Kings or presidents or or
anything there's it's just the inmates
running the Asylum you know and you you
elect them every couple months and
someone's in charge of the phone list
and someone's in charge of the book
table and you know um it's beautiful
you're like oh we're all you know there
we're there's no leaders there are only
trusted servants yeah yeah yeah that and
stuff like that gives you hope for the
future you know
um
but it's interesting and I don't want
this to be like a conversation that's
like dour
you know because also you have your show
that is kind of a search for happiness
kind of and I found it to be a real
Charming kind of you know like here's a
guy going to see where people are happy
and why
yeah so uh do you want to talk about
that at all I would love to talk about
that okay so the geography of bliss is a
travel show coming out
in late May on the peacock Network which
is where the office is where it lives
and breathes
uh and doesn't die it just keeps on
chugging it ever could
apparently we we thought it was dead
upon arrival but anyways he keeps
chugging along and but the geography of
bliss is um and I never thought I'd have
a better show than the office I really
really because nine Seasons 200 episodes
everyone got along
made a big impact was funny as hell
it's great character great money like
fun fun people everywhere oh yeah I saw
Kevin scoping chicks at a club once did
you and it was like the best time ever
so cool yeah
um but didn't you almost have a show
right before the office that didn't go
through yes that's good good memory yeah
I was supposed to be on this um
Janine Garofalo
uh TV show
and we did it and on the way to the
table read for it I ran into this TV
executive and he's like oh I'm so
excited we're going to do the American
version of The Office
and I had seen the English version I
loved it and I was like
ins I was outside I was like oh that's
great inside I was like [__] I want to
be on that
like okay you got to go to the table
read for this Gene and Janine's lovely
it's not about her but the pilot was
very good
we read the pilot Bob Odenkirk was in it
me and Bob Odenkirk nice man
um
and uh Mark Maron oh yeah yeah
and it went so the read through went so
bad they pulled the plug on the spot by
the time I got home they were like
they're not shooting they closed the
donuts up even uh and I was like inside
I was like I get to audition for the
office sure enough a month later
auditioned for the office and got and
got Dwight a few months after that so
had I gotten so you never know kitties
yeah sometimes a rejection and a
disappointment is a good thing and it
just is a a path forward where other
doors can open oh yeah what they say it
sucks to lose a limb until you're in a
um one-legged contest
are there a lot on one-legged contests
I'm not sure can you Google that Bob uh
Kid Rock has a one-legged brother
and every time I see him I say man you
think with all the money you have you
buy your brother or another prosthetic
leg yeah dude or an Android leg Yeah
Yeah Jesus you know like a bionic thing
yeah like a leg saber do you remember
the bionic man not like saber you never
saw The Bionic Man uh-uh
oh it was great I love the Little House
in the prayer we loved a lot of Michael
Landon stuff we loved a lot of
um Bonanza going back after Bonanza post
Bonanza I did like all in the family
because and I like The Jeffersons I like
Good Times
temporarily oh
is it cradle rip off
sometimes yeah I love that
um
so the geography of bliss is a show
where I travel around the world and I
look for happiness in other cultures so
it's like Anthony Bourdain but it's for
about happiness not food and we went to
Iceland Bulgaria Ghana West Africa
Thailand and then back here in Los
Angeles
and it's so fun man I love these kind of
conversations having deep meaningful but
fun and silly conversations and
um it's a it's a terrific show it's
really uplifting
um it's inspiring and hopeful people
need some hope these days remember I
told you that's your Divine
responsibility I appreciate that it's
yours too I think it's why we're even
having this conversation because we're
curious about hope you know yeah
people need hope it's a precious and
depleted resource
and uh there's a lot of pessimism out
there and we gotta we gotta turn that
pessimism around and uh make people
believe that there is a bright day there
is a Star Trek future for Humanity where
we can all get along and work together
and solve problems and make the world a
better place we do it we start small we
start on a podcast you start in a family
you start in a cul-de-sac and you spread
out from there and then you bring it to
your workplace
but we're not going to do it with the
the way the current media system is and
we're not going to do it with the way
that the current political partisan
politics system works in our country
it's uh it's killing us killing us well
some of it could be changed I mean one
thing that we haven't podcast started
was because people felt like they
couldn't get through into like sitcoms
talented comedians felt like they
couldn't get opportunities you know I'm
not saying just me but even like
predecessors in podcasts they wanted to
have a place to have a voice right yeah
because even acting is just a way you
want to be able to have a place to put
yourself in the world yeah you want to
be able to have a voice even if it's a
physical voice yeah you know
um so that's why that started and that's
made conversations more long form and
been able to get uh people's points
across like I remember seeing Bernie
Sanders on Joe Rogan right and
I've always been of the ilk that I think
they should have to have one candidate
you shouldn't be able to pick up if
you're Republican you shouldn't be able
to pick a republican vice president you
should have to have a democratic vice
president right and vice versa so that
that way you're always in contention of
idea yeah so you have to figure out the
best idea between the two of you in
order to get it enacted or bring It
Forward right force people to work
together right like I would have loved
probably uh Trump uh Bernie ticket right
because you're right you're going to see
two totals gonna throttle each other
they wouldn't have been at each other I
agree Trump would have crushed him like
a like a stick insect and that would
have just cost them the uh the
possibility of maybe getting elected but
you would have had to see two guys that
were different have to figure it out
together right
um but um yeah but I remember listening
to Bernie Sanders it was the first time
I got to hear him in a long point I
didn't hear a clip that the media said I
didn't hear like a two minute rebuttal
on a
um Joe Rogan is four and a half hours
long dude yeah you were there yeah put
it on when you go to sleep and you wake
up it's still on you'd love being in
there man have you ever been on there no
man it would be you guys would have a
really neat conversation I don't I don't
smoke pot I don't do Ayahuasca well
that's a good point
does that disqualify me no he doesn't do
Ayahuasca either but yeah you just have
to say I mean I don't wrestle
oh no I don't disqualify you I don't I
mean I try to wrestle for a year but I
kept getting hurt so badly and then I
don't smoke pot and then I'll do
Ayahuasca but
I don't know I mean some people consider
that different you know have different
thoughts about sobriety and that you
know yeah
um but I haven't done it in over a year
but I would maybe do it again I found it
to be really really helpful and really
ties You Back To Nature in a lot of ways
oh interesting
um but yeah I think uh what are we
talking about Bernie Sanders podcasts
but I got different voice yeah and I'll
listen to the whole thing and at first I
would have been like me would I listen
to Bernie Sanders I don't know but I I
was like oh this is he has some great
ideas it's like I get to know this guy
yeah right whether you like his idea
whatever is this like uh oh I feel like
I get to know this guy yeah you know
um
but
what's been uh
what was like where did you find some of
the best happiness you think in the
places you've been was there one place
that kind of or anything you noticed
over the course of uh the places you
went I I saw happiness all over which
was great
I
it's so funny because happiness you know
when I saw it when I saw like real
profound
Blissful Joy it was always about
connection with other people it was
always about connection you talk about
the 12-step meetings like
it was in a family or in a community or
uh with some kind of service project or
it's it's people connecting you know and
that's why covid was so devastating like
you know isolated us all we need
connection we thrive in connection you
know and uh but the happiest place and
it's my favorite place on the planet is
Iceland I [__] love Iceland have you
been there um
it's so cool I mean everyone goes there
I mean it's very popular
um you had a bright light we'll go see
the bright lights right yeah the the
people at night yeah the the
Aurora Borealis oh yeah I saw those I
went to Greenland and I got to see those
but it's like watching mother nature
Iceland is
um
Iceland is just do like image search
you're on image search can you scroll
through them
can you just go through oh look at that
um oh look at those children in Iceland
go look at them
look at them look at those look how
happy they are God they're happy is it
Iceland official tourist info for
Iceland but there's a pretty Icelandic
woman yeah wait let's look at travel to
Iceland with diabetes oh yeah down one
more down one more
that's not something I thought I would
see is traveling to Iceland let's go
there brother can you click on it
yeah oh wow oh that's cool I haven't
seen that
so I've been five times to Iceland
five times
it's so beautiful you can't even believe
it black sand beaches glaciers volcanoes
uh waterfalls every I remember one time
I took my family we went camping there
like in a camper van and then we were
like driving on the road and we're like
oh my God look at that waterfall and
we're like and I realize like we just
drove by a 200 foot waterfall and we
were like meh because we've seen 1 000
foot waterfalls you know and uh it's so
gorgeous uh the people are are wonderful
uh the food is expensive as hell really
oh yeah I had a
I had a pizza I think it cost like 80
bucks once does it cost a lot to warm it
up or something
well we when we were in the camper van
it was great because we would go to the
grocery stores and we would get like
Ramen and spaghetti and oatmeal and yeah
salads and and we would just kind of eat
and and then maybe once a day we'd get
like an expensive meal the fish is
fantastic there but it's so beautiful
there's whale watching
um it's I can't say enough good things
about it but the people are happy there
one of the reasons the people are happy
is and I don't know if a lot of your
viewers are gonna like this or not but
they trust their government they believe
in their government and there's a social
safety net because you pay a [__] ton of
taxes but the education is First Rate
there's the health care is through the
roof they will take care of you when
you're sick mental health the roads the
bridges everything is taken care of and
it just works you know and so you have
and in talking to icelanders like there
was this trust they feel like oh I can
if I get sick I can take some time off
and then I'm protected by by regulations
I'll be able to get my job back and I
you know there's this this net of
government is there for they believed
like it was there for them right you
know and we're we've sensed the Vietnam
War and over the last several decades
our trust in government has gone down
and you know truth be told our
government is not working in in huge
ways I mean it's yeah it's kind of
taking care of our highways and potholes
and you know maybe our street lights but
not a whole lot more than that and it's
yeah I mean even the U.S postal system
even the one person from the government
that stopped by your house every day
yeah you could give a cookie to or get a
pat on the head yeah and it wasn't even
molesting people you never heard postal
people molesting yeah never you can even
pull down their pants and write girl on
their back
you just never it never happened yeah
and they and and Amazon or they messed
the postal systems going there it's just
yes we've let the government really I
try to be really nice that postal work
oh shame yeah God bless you working so
hard for like just above minimum wage
and you were Santa to us when I was a
kid it was like right here we go now
it's like who cares oh the postman's
here who cares the Amazon guys here oh
new headphones
and the postman is just like that
ex-girlfriend man in the um just walking
back to Tori amos's house somewhere
[Laughter]
God it hurts man but yeah it's like
there were institutions that we had that
we had some pride do you what do you
think happened with our government you
know
um what do you think happened like you
said like after Vietnam War I know there
was like a lot of contention like
between Americans that thought it was
good and bad to be there you know I
remember seeing Forrest Gump but I blame
it on partisanship really I really do
and what does that mean when you say
partisanship I'm not sure what it is um
um that's uh the kind of uh Republican
versus Democrat okay me saying me versus
you me versus you seeking power above
all
um would rather see I'll never forget
like when Obama got elected and Rush
Limbaugh was like I hope he fails wow I
hope he fails because I'm against his
policies and I want him to not succe and
I was like wow you want because I want
even if Trump could elected and I wasn't
a huge fan but Trump I want wanted him
to succeed yeah I didn't want him to
fail I wanted him to make lives better
and to help fix things and I was kind of
hoping oh maybe he'll fix some broken
things uh but think about every election
cycle Theo think about this how much
money is spent on campaign ads it's
insane banner ads like and where's all
that money going it's going into the
coffers of MSNBC and Fox News and CNN
and all of these media Outlets that we
don't trust because they're so partisan
and they have such an agenda and they're
getting rich from it and they're going
to stay polarized because they're making
so much money from it but what if you
just took all of that hundreds of
millions of dollars what if you had no
comp campaign Finance you had government
campaign financing right you weren't
able to kind of like raise and spend
money willy-nilly and you took all that
money and put it towards you know fixing
things yeah you know schools and
hospitals and and whatnot and yeah
giving nurses a raise exactly you had an
announcement one day it was like Hey
we're gonna give every nurse a two
thousand dollar raise this year or every
teacher a two thousand you know how
excited everybody would be it'd be great
the um the uh you know the water fan the
first aid um actually can I take a pee
break
let's paint and then we'll wrap up
actually yeah yeah I gotta uh I gotta
pack I gotta leave tomorrow morning for
a two and a half week book tour really
yeah
it's exciting all over have you written
a book you have like a comedy book I
never have I've written some a lot of
chapters for a book about growing up and
uh some comedy stories about different
experiences and stuff yeah you know your
book would do you would do really well
thanks man it's really awesome to sit
here with you man oh it's my it's it's
awesome for me man I love your stories
about growing up and like your stories
about kids at school like we had a kid
in our in our school you always have
those oh yeah that's great well the
first Asian kid we ever had or allegedly
had you know we had
um
remember how Pizza Huts have those
unique rooftops on them yeah you know
what I'm talking about yeah of course
yeah like yeah yeah diamond shape yes
well one of those burnt down right in
Slidell Louisiana right and so and the
uh
the roof had fallen flat on the ground
kind of like at a little bit of an angle
right and people like said Asian people
live there you know okay so we heard
about it yeah and we got a taxi over
there to go look and it was just a um
you literally called a taxi yeah well
you've saved up money we saved 17 take a
taxi there that's them
yeah God and you looked for Asian people
inside of it we'd never seen it before
yeah burned down when it's on the ground
flushed on the ground it has a very kind
of look of the Orient do you know how
they cook pizzas at Pizza Hut have you
ever seen that last time I went in there
it's all automated oh it's uh they just
take they unwrap it from the plastic and
they put it on a thing it's like at one
of those like
hotels and it just goes through the oven
on the conveyor belt then it comes out
done oh yeah that's how that's how they
used to do it I think did they always do
it that way it was like the little
rolling thing it was just like kind of
like these things and it just kept
moving forward yeah it used to be a
pretty long oven is it really short now
or something
there's a long oven yeah I love the
pizza was good when I was young it was
the real it was a we used to go to the
one on Ballinger Way look up the Pizza
Hut on Ballinger Way Lake Forest Park
Washington
I don't know if it's still there I think
it's a Thai restaurant now speaking of
Asian people
oh yeah oh they'll start a restaurant in
an alinger way Asian people could
they'll start a restaurant in anything
um no
is there a lot of beautiful Asian people
up in uh
Washington yeah
um is there one on Ballinger Way no
it's closed down God but you know what
just look under images and see if they
have any let's get an old image of it
somebody took a snapshot of it there
there you go on the left probably it
right there
yeah
oh and there's my mom's Ford festive out
front she used to drive that deal yeah
God it was so small three cylinders oh
and one of the sellers was just us in
the back seat going
and she could beat us from that like the
front seat was so close that she could
beat everybody like she was playing the
drums dude why don't they have cars with
pedals like Flintstones kind of but like
just to get like a two-cylinder car yeah
but then everyone in the back seat is
doing this just to help it along kind of
and you get your workout we're also fat
yes Americans like
right win-win well that's almost an
example of everything that we've been
talking about like or some of the stuff
that would help Solutions Humanity okay
is if we every there was some sense of a
need for a vested interest and if people
felt like they were contributing you
know right
um yeah
yeah I mean
it's tough you know with this broken
political system I think you know in my
Faith Traditions called the Baha'i faith
there are
um
elections and it's kind of like a
12-step meeting it's it's a little
different but you elect what's called a
local Spiritual Assembly to go to guide
the Affairs of of your local community
and every year you do that and you write
down names silent ballot and you pray
and meditate and you think who's the
wisest most mature people to kind of
help
steer forward the Baha'i Community here
in Los Angeles or whatever you ponder it
and there's maybe a master list of
everyone who lives there and you write
them down and there's no campaigning
there's no yard signs there's no money
spent no one says I think I would make a
good assembly member and here's why
um it's all done silently and then you
put them in the envelope and then the
tellers count them and then nine people
are elected like why couldn't you do
that in a small town could you do that
in Covington Louisiana yeah because you
have people like no campaigning no one
no proselytizing no aggrandizing no one
saying like I should be the the mayor or
what have you and and just have people
gather at the local high school football
stadium and uh write down who they think
would best serve the Affairs of the
people of Covington Louisiana
yeah I think that it that that could
happen you know I think it's probably
and obviously it's you know it's
hypothetical because you look at a you
know obviously America is much bigger
but yeah you start to think what system
could be different I think a lot of
people are wondering now what system
people think that it's the system we
have is isn't helping us
you know um I think
yeah you start to wonder how could it be
because I'm glad you're saying that
because it's it really is like we keep
slapping Band-Aids on a broken system
and if the system is broken it's it's no
good you know it's like well we'll
change this policy or we'll pass this
bill or we'll get an increased funding
for this and it's just like slapping
Band-Aids on you know on a on a boat
full of Buckshot well I think you have
to have guys maybe possibly you have to
have someone they always that you hear
anyway that electing an independent
candidate getting one of them into the
runoff would shake up the the way that
the funds are distributed you also have
some interesting guys now like Bobby
Kennedy Jr right yeah so he's um he is a
Democrat but he has his
he's anti-vaccine yeah he's like uh yeah
he's anti is he an anti-vaxxer he is
he raised a lot of questions a ton of
concern about but I think he was
anti-vaxx before covet I think he's like
he's an environmentalist so he's always
been about the environment he's always
been about Let's test things before we
move them forward right
um I mean he has a book He's against Dr
fauci you know so it's like he's
definitely in that world right
um but it's interesting because he's
going to run the Democratic ticket right
I think you're starting to get
hopefully you're gonna start to get
candidates that are different
it's got to start to expand at some
point because it feels very railroaded
but isn't and that's true like if if we
opened it up and you had like
let's say you had Joe Rogan run or you
had Mark Cuban run or you know some
really interesting kind of thought
leaders or businessmen or entrepreneurs
that's cool but the system is still
I want the power I'm going to raise a
[__] ton of money I'm gonna go around
doing all these fundraising dinners I'm
going to be spending all these money on
these media Outlets because I want the
power for me and my cotary and we're
gonna try and put down you and your
little coteri of friends we're still in
that mode where we're not really in the
mode of Public Service you know they're
public servants they should be serving
the public so how do we just get out of
that whole campaigning thing all
together is what I say now maybe I'm
being naive and people are probably
rolling their eyes and like oh you
hippie you know but
uh but no it's okay to have that's a
great it's a I agree because people are
sick of all the wasted money the [__]
[__] the desperation by these
parties to get your vote the pandering
to poor people with fear videos and all
of this and using classes and cultures
as uh puppets and keeping people in
certain places just so they'll continue
to vote for you like I think everyone's
exhausted I think the heart of the world
is you know has arteriosclerosis you
know it feels that way and that's okay
look if that's okay if you and I are
sitting and talking about that and I
like that your book makes me think about
that yeah you know and not just the
negative sides of it or the problems
yeah but um but I talk at the end of my
book I have a chapter called Seven
Pillars for a spiritual Revolution and I
offer some tangible
Solutions some things and one of them is
what we talked about before which is
Hope and I said Foster joy and squash
cynicism because as long as we stay
cynical and pessimistic nothing gets
done if everyone's sitting back just
like ah it's a pile of [__] it'll never
work like then nothing will change and
it's just gonna get worse actually so
that's a really deadly trap and it's
it's super important that we you know we
as entertainers as storytellers you know
we try and Foster joy in people give
them hope and uh and don't let ourselves
get cynical too
you get cynical sometimes you fight on
you fight against cynicism oh yeah a
battle the dark arts I battle self-pity
sometimes okay which is a unique way
that uh cynicism kind of sneaks into you
I find yeah you know is me just you know
um so I just have to stay up stay stay
on top of it yeah you know and it's a
misery Brigade yeah it does and it does
get to be there you know I mean yeah
yeah but there's a lot of people doing
good stuff out there and that's another
way to look at things and to wake up and
think hey uh
you know there was a guy I wrote about
this guy in my book
um this guy named Callum Greaves and he
works with Greta tunberg and a lot of
Youth ambassadors for climate change and
whatever you think about Greta tunberg
putting that aside really brilliant guy
and he said to me you know I work on
clean air
because everyone can agree on clean air
some people on this side of the
political Spectrum might not think that
man-made CO2 is causing climate change
or that it people are being extremist
and and whatnot and people on this side
you know have different opinions but
clean air is something everyone can get
behind yeah you know you reduce you
don't want kids to get asthma right you
want your grandkids to have clean air
you know when you when you go to the
grave and that is a precious point of
unity from both sides and then it's
win-win because CO2 does get reduced but
you're also really focusing on the human
story which is making air cleaner for
kids so that's a way to look at like
solving a solution like climate change
like if we all just work together on
clean air like we would fix climate
change right letting these kids long up
and feel comfortable and happy yeah yeah
I like it man I can't I don't know if
I'll finish the whole book but I'm gonna
try at least go to the Seven Pillars at
the end I appreciate that I'm gonna uh
if you ever want me to read it to you
like a bedtime bedtime story or
something like that I can do that as
well
FaceTime yes put me on your pillow and
I'll read it to you okay
it's been a pleasure lunging up with you
I like that lung up yeah man
um I'm such a big fan I love your stuff
and so funny and
weird and wonderful and uh I think
you're doing great things and it's just
a pleasure to be in this room with you
and your friend yeah the Zachary Alex
yeah
um thank you man and thank you for all
the years of entertainment and also now
all the years of thought you know that
you're uh
you know it's like the second organ
inside you know it's like you got our uh
brains now you're going after our hearts
and our brains you know oh thank you man
I appreciate that I like it man Rayne
Wilson man uh anytime man uh and we'll
get the book and we'll put it up right
here I love it thank you Soul Bloom guys
it'll be boom so sorry Soul boom guys
it's available now or it'll be available
soon and um Rayne Wilson
[Music]
I must
I must Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life I found I
can feel
it in my bones
but it's gonna take